a week after the assassination attempt
against justice brett kavanaugh the
liberal media well they've seemed to
move on
abc nbc cbs and cnn sunday shows
completely ignored the targeted attack
on the supreme court justice zero
seconds of coverage
focusing instead on the january 6th
congressional hearings
well liberal comic bill maher is
condemning the new york times for
burying the assassination attempt
the new york times buried this yeah it
was like anything below the fold if this
had been a liberal supreme court justice
that someone came to kill it would have
been on the it would have been on the
front page and that's what's so
disappointing about a paper like the new
york times
because they just wear their bias on
their sleeves and they if it's not part
of something that feeds our narrative
and as democrats stall on a bill to beef
up security for our judges the wall
street journal publishing an op-ed
pointing out the vulnerability of these
justices to political violence let's go
to our justice there really is a
vulnerability an intimidation campaign
against justices you know it is
it really is shocking that we're in a
situation where number one the attorney
general of the united states you know
just pl
pays word homage to the idea that oh
these things are a destruction to
democracy when he won't arrest the
people who are clearly violating the
federal statute
18 usc 1507 he could arrest all of those
people in front of their homes
but they won't do it and the mainstream
media is complicit you know we've been
saying this for months and months but
the truth is that there is in this
country a destruction of not just the
the criminal justice system but of our
institutions
and the democrat party is responsible
for it when you attempt to assassinate a
supreme court justice and you have all
the tools to do it
and they ignore it
just as he said i mean just as bill
maher said if it were so to my or forget
it i mean there it would be it would be
running five days a week but it shows
you that they don't care about justice
it's an ideology and the more i see it
the more it convinces me that just like
the democrat ideology you know we're not
going to out joe the guy can't walk he
can't talk he trips up air force one
twice now you know he's cognitively
deficient one minute he's going the next
minute he's not going he doesn't even
know if he's going and yet they cover it
all the time jessica you don't have to
defend all of liberal media but you can
try if you want i mean zero minutes
is this intentional is it not worthy of
a story
obviously it was on some list and they
decided other stories were more
important i do think that it's something
to cover it matters and there are
liberal justices that i
you know i hope everyone will be treated
equally in this i think that it was a
mistake on their part to not at least
talk about it obviously there's going to
be a bill about this which i think is
going to go through this week um i don't
know about a violation of the law to
have people peacefully protesting
outside the guy who did show up to kill
him called the police and turned himself
in
his gun was not loaded he did not
attempt to enter the house he saw
security and then sat down and called
9-1-1 on himself
but it should have been covered
obviously it's a big story and everyone
needs to know that it's happening um and
that unfortunately because of how
uh politically radical our country is
right now i'm sure more things like this
will happen is this yeah jesse is this
where we are
intimidation of justices and political
violence or is this a roe v wade thing
this is this is so central
to the democratic narrative well it is
roe v wade
centric but before there was a lot of
threats and intimidation against trump
supporters and some of the vicious
treatment of trump himself i mean they
threw all of his people in jail i mean
they used swat teams at the dead of
morning to go wake them up and
cuff them i mean just look what they did
in navarro yeah i mean like shackles and
full body cavity search riddle me this
peter
if a tree falls in the forest and no
one's there to hear it does it make a
sound
philosophers have been debating this
metaphysical question for years because
does it take human consciousness to
perceive something to mean it exists
that is what the broadcast networks
feel it is their duty to do if they
don't cover something it does not exist
hunter's laptop does not exist left-wing
assassination attempts do not exist and
that's a really powerful tool look what
they did during the run-up to the
election remember they didn't cover warp
speed no one knew about warp speed no
one knew about that we just put up a 33
gdp number on the eve of the election no
one knew about the mideast peace deal so
you get a country
that you know half the country
that wasn't i'm talking about the
broadcasts
half the country thinks there's only
right wing violence right half the
country thinks it's only white mass
shooters there's no black shooters and
then other half of the country thinks
the biden family is clean and the trump
family is dirty so you get half the
country's just disoriented and the other
half of the country's paranoid and
distrustful of the mainstream media but
that's how they want us pete they want
us divided of course they do absolutely
and we're as divided as ever to the
point where we're protesting outside of
supreme court justices homes almost no
coverage of something of at the very
minimum was potential violence and
political intimidation and now you've
got shut down dc activists trying to
literally shut down
the court yes and also uh there's just
no coverage of what's happening in their
neighborhoods where all these protests
are there one it's illegal to protest in
front of a federal judge's home i'm
going to say it every day until the
attorney general decides to do something
about actually enforcing the law because
the other thing that's happening is law
enforcement and it's not going out there
doing anything about it so neighbors of
kavanaugh's were like gosh guys this is
our home and so they are trying to
gently confront protesters and this
becoming a very uncomfortable situation
for them
and then i just want to mention one
thing about aoc we mentioned we talked
about her in the a block something
different watch this instagram video
where she runs she says she ran to the
floor of the house in order to block the
security bill for supreme court justices
oh yeah and she's so proud of it and i
think well wow let's add that to your
resume never pass a single bill single
single-handedly basically set back the
climate change movement
and
now is basically preventing supreme
court justices from getting the help
that they need she says it's because a
gun bill hasn't passed so why should
justice system get secured the thing
that they don't want to talk about is
how they didn't want to show um that the
right had any points that they could
make about roe v wade and the left and
political and idol ideological violence
the amazing part is it passed the house
at the end of may we were in the end of
june past the second sentence
yeah they'll do it now because they've
been pressured but it took us to
pressure them absolutely right and uh
trees do make a sound because we have
microphones even if there's no one there
to hear it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else